Well the kernel, as we've written it, uses 32 by 32 threads, or 1,024 threads,
and the limit on my machine is 2,048 threads.
That's keeping us down to no more than 2 thread blocks per SM.
The kernel requires 7 registers for each of those threads, so that's a total of 7,168 registers.
The limit is 65,536 registers per SM.
So this is limiting us to no more than 9 thread blocks per SM. This is not the limit.
The kernel is requesting 4 kilobytes of shared memory to store the tile. The limit is 48k.
So, this is restricting us to 12 blocks per SM, That's not our limiting factor.
And finally, there's a limit of 8 thread blocks per SM total, and that's clearly not the limiting factor.
So in the end, the thing that's keeping us from running more thread blocks per SM,
and therefore keeping us from running more threads per SM is this first limit,
the maximum number of threads per SM.
We're limited to running 2 thread blocks per SM,
and that means that we're going to be running a total of 2,048 threads on each SM.